c'est une histoire qui dure depuis
maintenant quinze ans le 19 avril à
paris pierre bédier nasser al-khelaifi
se sont rencontrées pour la signature
d'une convention liant le département
des yvelines à la fondation psg un
engagement en faveur de la jeunesse qui
se poursuivra jusqu'en 2017
c'est une tradition puisque les yvelines
ont été quasiment à l'origine un
partenaire de cette fondation et à cette
tradition c'est la tradition de
solidarité
il faut que les sportifs de haut niveau
soit un exemple un exemple concret et
donc qu'ils aillent vers les plus jeunes
vers les plus faibles pour leur apporter
du plaisir du bonheur et puis les
inciter au 6e même à regarder vers le
haut dit sportif document
la karabatic et daniel narcisse après
leur sacre de champion de france sous
les couleurs du psg handball souvenu
enflammé le stade devant mille jeunes de
la fondation savart temps pour le club
après savoir temps ci pour nous les
joueurs de pouvoir à travers la
fondation donner un peu de notre temps
pour les enfants pour les enfants en
difficulté sociale et les voir voilà ce
qu'on ait notre nom pour un autographe
ou une photo ça fait vraiment chaud au
coeur la fondation avec notre partenaire
gfie ils ont réussi à réaliser une super
belle journée
voile enthousiaste pour les enfants les
gamins sont super contents d'être là
faty salaires en vacances
le fait de pouvoir leur proposer une
journée comme ça c'est 200 yvelinois
étaient présents sur cette journée un
contrat qui permet surtout aux jeunes
chinois de la fondation de continuer à
bénéficier des activités mises en place
quand ça clairefontaine engagement sur
le handicap ou invitations aux
entraînements privés
mais aujourd'hui il ne fallait pas
oublier que psg ne rime pas qu'avec
football